deux invités vous nommez gardanne chefs
de service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière médecin réanimateur et
françois pupponi député du val d'oise
mouvement démocrate modem on les écoute
tout de suite bonsoir messieurs merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
rouvrir les restaurants au déjeuner pour
ceux qui en font la demande est ce une
bonne idée selon vous à bruno m'égare
ban alors je crois que c'est un tout
petit peu plus mature et malheureusement
nous avons un mois devant nous de tous
les dangers
effectivement avec le retour des
vacances avec la réouverture des écoles
avec l'augmentation désormais au delà de
70 % de la prévalence des variants
contagieux
on a un risque non négligeable d'une re
démarrage de l'épidémie
voire même si on croit les projections
fait par les épidémiologistes d'une
croissance exponentielle
or l'hôpital est déjà totalement saturée
dans beaucoup de régions
il me paraît plus prudent pour le moment
de rester comme launay mais bien sûr de
préparer une éventuelle sortie de cette
période difficile par contre le 30 mars
c'est encore trop précoce pour dire que
ce sera possible à cette date
françois pupponi est ce que vous estimez
vous également que cette réouverture à
partir du 30 mars est trop à trop
précoce ils disent tous la même chose
pas continuer comme ça il faut qu'avant
ils sachent niveau
deuxièmement il aurait près de personnel
les personnels sont ailleurs maintenant
et donc même si le mans alors dû de
réouvrir les gens ont des difficultés et
il faut qu'ils sachent dans quelle
direction va et c'est ça la grande
difficulté il faut qu'on leur dise vous
la préparez vous éventuellement recruter
des personnes on espère quand même aller
si c'est pas le 30 mars a peut être le
30 avril mai mais que l'on sache où on
va mais dirait des restaurateurs ça fait
tellement vous êtes fermés et ça va
continuer encore six mois un an
même s'ils ont des zi le gouvernement
accordées les aides conséquentes la
situation n'est pas acceptable et on
sait très bien que le jour où ça va
repartir
il y aura des dépôts de bilan il y aura
des gens trouveront pas réouvrir voilà
donc ils disent mais expliquez nous
donnons leur la tribune que nous avons
signé à l'initiative de notre collègue
ramos c'est de dire mais voilà que l'on
sache ce que l'on fait il faut savoir
aussi que les restaurateurs ont le droit
de l'ouvrir pour permettre aux
entreprises du btp de pouvoir se
restaurer parce qu'on dit aux autres
mais de btp travailler ou d'autres
continuer travailler et vous avez droit
de manger au restaurant donc
effectivement une partie des restaurants
seraient ouverts uniquement pour les
entreprises du btp
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un besoin
parce qu'on peut pas dire l'activité
économique avait continué les gens
doivent se restaurer puis les
restaurants dans la vie c'est de rester
fermés et le françois monique les bars
et restaurants avaient en plus fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour respecter les
contraintes sanitaires elles ont donc
malgré tout était fermé
que pourrait faire de plus pour que le
gouvernement accepte une réouverture
prochaine journée contre l'as pas les
gens viennent d'acheter la nourriture
les gens viennent acheter la nourriture
dans les restaurants et vont manger
après dans des salles ou chez eux où ils
sont une quinzaine une vingtaine champ
proche de précaution c'est aussi ça la
réalité c'est que les gens sur une liste
chez eux
bon et on voit bien qu'ils aient moment
ils font crohas lors il ya bien sûr la
situation sanitaire qui est la plus
importante mais il faut aussi que l'on
puisse continuer à fonctionner en
prenant toutes les précautions possibles
il faut bien sûr respecter leur
sanitaire mais il faut retrouver un
semblant de vie à peu près normale dans
la mesure du possible et s'était attiré
de la tribune renault mégane en prenant
en compte ces derniers chiffes de santé
publique france environ vingt mille cas
supplémentaires depuis hier 122 nouveaux
décès à l'hôpital
est ce que ça pourrait être possible
prochainement de d'envisager d'ouvrir
des restaurants pour le déjeuner alors à
nous faut actuellement nous sommes
plutôt sur un plateau très haut avec une
tendance à la reprise l'augmentation des
cas de nouvelles contaminations
attention il faut pas se fier aux
chiffres du week end car évidemment
comme vous le savez les données ne
remonte pas aussi rappelé
manquant semaine il faut regarder les
chiffres se lisser sur la semaine et
malheureusement depuis maintenant
quelques jours la baisse que nous avions
enregistré il ya une quinzaine de jours
c'est assez et on a dans beaucoup de
départements de région une tendance à la
réorientation
alors certes une augmentation pour le
moment relativement lente mais
effectivement le risque avec la reprise
des activités scolaires professionnels
la semaine prochaine dans les grandes
métropoles il pourrait y avoir une
accélération plus importante donc à
nouveau je pense que je comprends
entièrement qu'il faille donner des
perspectives à tous les commerçants à
tous les restaurateurs à tous les les
propriétaires de bars je crois que
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement difficile car où naviguent à
peu près à deux à trois jours près
maintenant il est probable que si les
choses se passaient convenablement au
cours du mois de mars début avril on
puisse plus sereinement pouvoir
construire la sortie à partir de cette
crise actuelle ce d'autant plus
évidemment que le nombre de personnes
vaccinées notamment parmi les sujets
âgés et à risque va considérablement
augmenter
enfin on l'espère autre problème
souligné dans cette tribune ne pas
perdre ce qui aurait encore envie de
travailler dans les restaurants les
signataires donc de cette tribune parle
d'une pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui
pourrait être aggravée en raison de la
crise qu'en pensez-vous françois pupponi
ces deux réalités tous les restaurateurs
de 10 et en particulier par exemple ceux
qui sont dans des activités saisonnières
ils savent très bien que dans la
perspective d'ouvrir ou le pas ouvrir
ils ne peuvent pas recruter est longue
les salariés qui ont besoin de vivre et
c'est normal vont aller chercher de
l'employeur il fois qu'ils devront être
employé ailleurs et ne trouveront plus
le personnel pour ouvrir donc l'idée
c'est peut-être de dire ok embaucher il
y aura du chômage partiel pour ce qui
sera embauchée y compris pour la saison
dans l'attenté de la réouverture
donc il ya une dette publique et le jour
où vous rêvez vous avez le personnel
mais si on ne donne pas ses perspectives
et de soutien aux restaurateurs
ils auront même le jour où ça réouvrira
ils ont un vrai problème pour re trouver
du personnel compétent capable de
travailler dans des bonnes conditions
donc l'inquiétude des restaurateurs
c'est aussi celle là c'est de dire mais
nous nous sommes en train de perdre nos
compétences nous sommes en train de
perdre les personnes qui sont capables
de nous aider à fonctionner en
respectant nos clients et donc il faut
aussi entendre aujourd'hui j'appelle si
on fait l'effort pendant un an ils sont
prêts à continuer à faire l'effort pour
raisons sanitaires qu'on peut comprendre
mais ils nous disent si nous n'avons pas
nous la possibilité de garder notre
personnel alors nous gardons nos savoir
faire vous pensez-vous françois pupponi
que cette proposition ne pourra aboutir
que gouvernement serait d'accord pour
rouvrir ses restes en nombre c'est
quelque part un appel nous ont ouvert le
bal en virée le discours en fait c'est
finalement cette tribune
non mais écoutez ce que les
restaurateurs il faut préparer la
reprise
on espère qu'avec la vaccination qu'avec
les mesures qui ont été prises
on va enfin pouvoir et ouvrir un moment
il ya une activité normale 3 reprendre
on l'espère que ça sera le plus tôt
possible même s'il faut prendre aucun
risque
mais il faut la préparer cette reprise
est aujourd'hui la grande difficulté
pour les restaurateurs en particulier
celle de perdre leurs compétences et le
personnel qu'ils avaient s'ils le
perdent mail si demain on leur dit mme
perreault et ils n'auront pas la
possibilité parce que sans cuisinier
sans serveur ou 100 personnels
compétents ils n'auront pas les
compagnies n'auront pas les capacités
d'ouvrir donc c'est une vraie question
est donc c'est une manière d'interpeller
le gouvernement sur ce sujet qui est un
sujet de préoccupation majeure est ce
que l'une des solutions à vous nommez
gagne ce n'est pas aussi peut-être
essentiellement cette campagne de
vaccination bien sûr c'est la seule
porte de sortie de cette crise
actuellement on sait désormais que le
vaccin est parfaitement efficace pour
prévenir les formes graves de
l'infection pour prévenir même les
formes mineures voire les contaminations
donc les données venant d'israël en vie
réelle sur un très grand nombre de la
population sont extrêmement positifs on
pense même évidemment que lorsqu'on
atteindre un certain nombre de personnes
vaccinées on pourrait
réduire les contaminations de ceux qui
ne sont pas vaccinés et donc
probablement évidemment très rapidement
s'orienter vers une reprise quasi normal
de la vie
maintenant on est au un stade un peu
difficile c'est à dire pour le moment le
pourcentage de personnes vaccinées y
compris parmi les personnes âgées n'est
pas encore suffisant pour éviter tous
les dangers et malheureusement avec
l'augmentation de prévalence des
variants plus contagieux qui arrive
désormais aux environs de 50 à 70%
il y à un risque non nul d'accélération
de l'épidémie
il faut donc pour le moment rester
concentré sur la période que nous devons
vivre rappeler à tout le monde
l'importance des de respecter les
mesures barrières le port du masque être
extrêmement prudent y compris les
week-ends notamment si l'on veut
évidemment éviter des mesures de
restriction encore plus importante qui
nous menacent notamment en ile de france
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec le
directeur général de la santé qui
considèrent veut que le couvre-feu et
efficace pour stopper et freiner la
propagation du coup vie de 19 françois
pupponi oui valcourt et j'ai pas de
compétence pour contester les chiffres
il a été rejoint la santé on espère
qu'il est efficace le gouvernement
impose un peu y compris la
responsabilité de leurs parents confient
les je pense que tu fais de mon point de
vue c'est une bonne chose je sais pas si
le médecin sera d'accord avec moi et de
mon point de vue c'est une bonne chose
car les français on aurait peut-être eu
du mal à supporter un nouveau
confinement
on espère que le pari qu'ils étaient
pris d'assaut un pari sur un gagnant et
qu'effectivement vannes et empêcher
éviter que la france se recombinent on
verra bien où il ya une réunion mercredi
importante
l'elysée se communiquera ou matignon
mais oui faisons tout pour l'été
confident en respectant bien entendu
l'élan sanitaires et en limitant les
risques pour la santé des français
mais effectivement aujourd'hui si le
couvre-feu et efficace alors oui on aura
évité le confinement on n'aura pas
pénalisé une partie de l'économie on
n'aura pu permettre au pays de
fonctionner le du possible de la manière
la plus normale possible et si ça
continue comme ça grâce aux
investigations comme vient de le dire le
médecin alors oui on aura réussi quelque
chose d'intéressant mais on sait très
bien que la seule solution c'est la
vaccination
on espère que les choses vont continuer
à s'accélérer le mot de la fin pour vous
à bruno megaman ce couvre-feu
vous pensez que c'est efficace en
complément avec la campagne de
vaccination le couvre-feu nous a permis
pendant au moins un mois d'éviter des
mesures de restriction plus strictes
notamment ce fameux confinement
nationale que tout le monde redoutait
donc un mois de plus de sursis pour la
vie sociale l'activité économique que le
psychisme de chacun d'entre nous c'est
quelque chose d'important
maintenant est-ce que le couvre-feu a
permis partout de contrôler l'épidémie
malheureusement non on voit que dans les
régions de l'ouest de la france par
exemple typiquement en est
en aquitaine le couvre-feu a été
parfaitement efficaces pour contrôler la
progression de l'épidémie voie pour
permettre sa régression
actuellement le r0 est inférieur à 1
al'inverse dans d'autres régions comme à
nice comme en moselle comme en ile de
france comme dans le nord les choses
sont plus difficiles ce couvre feu qui
était appliquée de la même façon n'a pas
permis de contenir l'épidémie
celles ci progressent alors on voit bien
qu'il ya d'autres facteurs qui se
surajoutent comme le mode de vie le type
d'habitation les habitudes de la
population et le niveau de respect des
mesures barrières règle très clairement
les grandes villes vont être en
difficulté dans les jours à venir ou
bono merga ben meghar ban chef du
service de réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière médecin réanimateur et
merci à vous également françois pupponi
député du val d'oise ou mouvement
démocrate et démocrate apparenté
merci à vous